alex et marie-soleil angoisse à quelques
minutes du triathlon de l'école sainte
madeleine
suivant notre stress tiempo c'est la
cause des épreuves de plus à surmonter
pour ces deux jeunes qui ne sont pas
faciles
marie-soleil 11 ans revient de loin
elle souffre de dyspraxie un trouble qui
affecte la coordination des mouvements
la structure des idées la dame qui
l'avait évaluée à lavezzi c'est une
inapte danse pas impossible de faire
trois autres cas pas y passer mais près
de marie-soleil vivait dans sa bulle
peinait à écrire à lire fui l regard
puis il y avait les crises
et alors me choquer des transferts au
dos on appelle une fois le démon est
tellement enfin on pouvait alex 13 ans
souffre du tdah et de troubles anxieux
l'an dernier sa mère a reçu un
diagnostic de cancer rare de quoi
chambouler son univers je sois vraiment
stressé parce que je pense à manquer ste
marie mines pis je pense tout le temps
c'est les résultats scolaires d'alex ont
plongé la motivation aussi en plus du
comportement des fois il peut faire des
petites crises
des fois ils sont un plot pile c'est
j'arrive à l'école de trois fois qu'ils
n'y assistent pas parce que ta maman
malade que tous voter les enfants
marie soleil a travaillé pendant deux
ans en thérapie pour réorganiser ses
circuits neurologiques
elle a réappris à marcher parler penser
un chemin ardu mais payant fait un
enfant heureuse et ça je les ai pas vus
dans les cinq premières années de sa vie
je me sens vraiment vélocité mon père et
mon petit mais là aujourd'hui simon mon
amie jeanne d'or pour se calmer
alex visite le local des techniciens en
éducation spécialisée son comportement
s'est améliorée tout comme la santé de
maman c'est le départ malgré les
encouragements de sa mère alex fige dans
la piscine sa bête noire le kaki vu
qu'il voulait pas faire la liste du
chiite et un royal ex fait les bons
moments
marie soleil est l'une des premières à
sortir de l'eau avant il est à vélo mais
à la course à pied elle perd son sourire
son père poulx avec elle pour cet enfant
qui a horreur des comparaisons c'est pas
capable de voir que dix autos d'hydra
dieu moi je suis 6e peuvent même poste à
l'ex en arrachent même si bouger pour
lui est devenu un exutoire samana ou
bing
camara quand ça ça m'aide à oublier que
j'utilise safari c'est juste soit fier
de lui du monde qui est une première une
50e place à l'arrivée
la pression tombe
pour le faire d'abord réussi à faire
appliquer le même s'il a une vraie
nature et le fait pour moi il me lévy on
a eu 1 nrj en forme je suis content
montage parce que j'ai réussi - avoir un
kilomètre de course tout les mouvements
étaient tellement dur pour yelle de
coordonner socle de la voir faire un
triathlon c'est comme whaou
[Musique]